well it looks like we are starting to
learn more and more about Sony's plans
and Marvel studios's plans for
Spider-Man it also looks like for those
fans who have been waiting for this
which I believe is everyone it looks
like we're going to have sort of a
three-way crossover happening pretty
soon meaning not only are the MCU and
the Sony spider Versa going to cross
over but also the animated spiderverse
from into the spiderverse seems to be
probably Crossing over sometime pretty
soon in the future and we've actually
started to see this connect even more
after Loki season 2's finale if you
noticed in Spider-Man across the
spiderverse we saw the Multiverse tree
and if you haven't seen the finale of
Loki season 2 mute this for about 10
seconds we also saw igdrasil at the end
of Loki season 2 and it looked very
similar to the Multiverse tree that we
saw in Spider-Man across the spiderverse
so a lot is happening between Sony and
Marvel Studios and the animated
spiderverse and it looks like the next
project that that we could be getting
that is not a solo Venom or Spider-Man
project is a Sinister 6 project that
Sony is currently working on we'll break
down everything you need to know in this
video but if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Spider-Man news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick one winner
at the end of each month so let's first
talk about the Sinister 6 Spider man
spin-off film that is reportedly in
development right now at Sony then we'll
talk about how the Animated Universe not
just from Sony but also from Marvel
Studios as what if how both of these
animated universes could start to bleed
into the liveaction universe in the MCU
and how we could see some of these
animated characters pop up in liveaction
in Avengers Secret Wars and we're
specifically going to be talking about
Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 so stay
tuned for that but first the Sinister 6
according to Insider Daniel rpk right
now Sony Pictures is currently
developing a Sinister 6 movie featuring
its Spider-Man spin-off characters now
keep in mind that Sony has actually been
teasing this for quite some time now way
back at the end of 2019 executive
producer for the Spider-Man films and
Sony Amy Pascal has already teased these
plans she stated and I quote these
villains we now have in our universe
happen to be the characters that are in
the Sinister 6 there may be something
that happened with that and she actually
stated this in a featurette that was
made specifically for Spider-Man far
from home so they have been planning
this for a while but the fact that she
did it for Spider-Man far from home
leads us to believe that this could be
Tom Holland Spider-Man who is going to
be the Spider-Man for this film here's
the thing though in order for that to
happen either some of the villains have
to go into the MCU or Spider-Man has to
go into the Sony spiderverse now this is
where it gets a little bit tricky
because there are a lot of villains in
each universe that we all want to see in
the Sinister 6 for example we know
Kingpin now exists in the MCU we saw him
introduced in Hawkeye he's going to be a
main character in Ekko and then in
Daredevil so he's in the MCU however
over in the Sony spiderverse of course
we have venom it is very clear that a
version of vulture is in the Sony
spiderverse right now based off what we
saw in that morbius post credit scene
and then of course you have morbius
himself if Sony wants to continue to use
that character it certainly did seem
like they were sort of setting up a team
up in a Sinister Six with that post
credit scene with vulture and morbius
and now they have Madam Webb coming out
and we're not really too sure right now
what the result of that is going to be
perhaps she sees something happen in the
future that is caused by Spider-Man so
she teams up with some of these other
villains in order to try and prevent it
from happening it depends on what Sony
wants to do with that story and then of
course we have Craven the Hunter coming
and there's a little Spider-Man tease in
the trailers that we've seen so far for
craving the Hunter they've specifically
showed us a scene that had spiders in it
on webs and we know that's intentional
obviously so that's five villains but we
do know that other villains exist in the
MCU like scorpion chameleon and like I
said we would love to see Spider-Man go
up against Kingpin which no doubt we
will see at some point in time but the
question is will he be a part of this
Sinister 6 team and which universe will
it take place in keep in mind The
Insider my time to shine hello stated
not too long ago that we are going to
see Spider-Man and Venom go up against
each other sooner than we think
specifically referring to Tom Hardy's
Venom and Tom Holland's Spider-Man so
it's not a case of yes Tom Hardy's Venom
went into the MCU left a piece of the
Venom symbiote in but went back to the
Sony spiderverse now that piece of the
Venom symbiot will attach to a variant
of Eddie Brock in the MCU and that
person is going to go on to fight Peter
Parker that's not what we're talking
about here we're talking about Tom Hardy
vers Tom Holland because that's what
everybody wants to see people love Tom
Hardy as Venom people love Tom Holland
as Spider-Man and Tom Hardy has already
teased Venom versus Spider-Man a lot
remember after Venom 2 he stated that if
they're in the Olympics Spider-Man
versus Venom is the gold medal and they
would be crazy not to go for gold so we
could see this in venom 3 perhaps but if
not it looks like this Sinister 6
project that is in development of course
will have venom on it and if it's Tom
Holland Spider-Man which I believe it
will be this could be the film where we
get Venom verse Spider-Man I personally
would really love an actual Sinister 6
movie the only question I have for you
all is which Universe would you like to
see this take place in the Sony
Spider-Man universe or the MCU also
here's the thing in Deadpool 3 the
Multiverse is essentially going to start
collapsing yes Loki saved the Multiverse
but he gave every single person Free
Will which means Ks are coming and other
villains are coming as well and we
already know that Deadpool 3 is going to
show us some incursions and we're going
to see a lot of different Heroes from
different universes coming together in
one which sounds absolutely fantastic
and this opens up pretty much unlimited
possibilities and like I mentioned in
the beginning one of those unlimited
possibilities is the animated universes
going into live action if you saw
Spider-Man across the spiderverse you
already saw a live-action character go
into the Animated Universe Donald Glover
AKA childish gambinos Prowler so we
already know it's possible and
incursions are going to start happening
and since the Animated Universe is just
simply a Universe in the Marvel
Multiverse we could see some crossovers
here in fact Alex Perez from the cosmic
circus.com who was right about a lot of
Loki leaks for season 2 in fact I think
he was right about all the leaks has
just teased a little connection between
Kang the Conqueror and Spider-Man 2099
he tweeted yesterday the MCU Multiverse
was originally discovered by a scientist
in the 31st Century we know the story
after that multiversal war sacred
timeline Multiverse tree Etc that being
said if the Multiverse was first
discovered in the 31st Century who
taught him about it in 2099 this
certainly is a very interesting question
and we could certainly theorize about
this in a lot of different ways but the
big takeaway here is that there seems to
be some type of a connection between the
mcu's Multiverse and the spider verse
that is from the animated series and
honestly think about this scenario for a
second Oscar Isaac voices Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 2099 Oscar Isaac also plays
moonnight how awesome would it be to see
Oscar Isaac on screen in Avengers Secret
Wars as a liveaction Miguel oara but
also as moonight that would be awesome
to see and I bet the dialogue between
the two of them would be epic as well
and that is something that I think a lot
of fans are just extremely excited for
for Avengers Secret Wars the possibility
of one actor playing two different
characters like Chris Evans returning to
play both Captain America but also
playing Johnny Storm aka the Human Torch
of the Fantastic 4 because of course he
played that character too for the
original Fantastic 4 again we already
know that with the Multiverse and with
Avenger Secret Wars the possibilities
are Limitless so Miguel O'Hara coming
into live action is something that we
could honestly probably expect because
he does seem to know quite a lot about
the Multiverse but Alex P did pose that
question who taught him about it which
is very interesting CU it could be Kang
why would Kang tell him who knows that's
something I'm very much looking forward
to finding out in the vers Saga along
with Spider-Man vers Venom and a
Sinister 6 film let us know your
thoughts about all of this news in the
comments down below what are you most
excited for right now in both the MCU
and the Sony Spider-Man liveaction
spiderverse and the animated spiderverse
let us know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below please don't forget
to give the video a like And subscribe
to stay up to date on all the latest
Marvel news you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
woof